j assure marc du montet qui est un
excellent producteur moi jean marc est
un pote a dit qu'il ne fallait pas céder
à la psychose
il rappelle que sans rire du public
l'émission pour reconnaître une baisse
d'audience et il a bien raison
tpm paix pourrait être bientôt tourner à
huit clos je vous le dis c'est
impossible c'est possible on vient quand
même
oui bien sûr on vient je vais vous
expliquer ce qui se fait ce qui va se
faire
pensant 4 d'extrême urgence le choix
gril depuis j'ai j'ai un petit peu
anticipé la chose je vous jure que c'est
vrai comme d'habitude si éventuellement
le public n'est plus autorisé à venir
assister à tpm paix dans un premier
temps je mettrai donc en place des fous
rires j'ai des choses à redire
donc j'aurai une boîte avec des fous
rires ça donc voilà et le public
malheureusement un rat dégoûté que vous
deveniez pas cessé dans un deuxième
temps on passe un cap un et qu'il nous
demande de rester confinés sachez que
j'ai déjà commencé à mettre des
installations dans les loges pour qu'on
soit filmé 24 24 mais non et quand
soient confinés ensemble ce n'est pas du
tout une blague je vous le dis dans
récent ensemble on doit on semble
s'orienter dans ce cas on parle à nos
gendarmes ont fait normalement ces 14 14
donc on passera les 14 jours ensemble
dans les locaux ici les studios et j'ai
commencé déjà à étudier
je vais mettre des caméras automatiques
bien entendu parce que je veux le moins
deux cadreurs possible parce que je me
sois non plus les mettre en danger
voilà forcément et c'est moi qui vous ai
qui prend son bain
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
pas une vanne voilà on sera tous
ensemble et comme ça on pourra offrir un
programme et on veut aux téléspectateurs
et si comme ce commission des lois
nécessaires pour les douches sont 120
hertz il très bonne question peut passer
maintenant confinement dans un palace
parisien
c'est pas du tout une bonne étude rsa ce
week end je suis venue exprès ce
week-end pour voir comment on pouvait
installer des caméras ottomane en dira
voilà donc je vous dis c'est ce qu'il
fera en car de confinement sachez le et
c'est officiel je vous le dis voilà
après on va kiffer et puis on exigera de
de passer à côté de dire ça mais il a dû
observer une classe pour fatou n'ont
bien sûr pas qu'on sera là bien exact
qu'un plus un alors on peut venir avec
un plus ou un moins un nom mais voilà jo
maso stade iii le public est maintenant
à huawei ambitions face au stade